let me give another
okay hi everyone we are here for a wolf
language design review part about
language completeness and consistency
series
and today we're hearing about diff tools
um
tools for diffing notebooks
so Lou take it away and just by way of
introduction uh so Lou and I have been
working on this for a long time neon
helping Lou with the design and Lou on
the implementation uh what you're seeing
here by long means 10 years or what yeah
several years uh off and on I you know
it gets down prioritized and such uh so
it's not like constantly but there were
hard problems here and
the uh What uh we don't have every sort
of visualization and interactive tools
sort of cracked so I I want to set the
the expectations the expectations are we
believe that we've uh that we've
reasonably cracked all of the core
algorithm and data structure problems
and we have some basic visualizations as
well uh but but those are things that
you know we can continue to build out
also this isn't just about notebooks
this covers a lot of territory including
basic expressions and that's kind of the
simpler portion of this so that's where
Lou is going to begin and with that I'll
I'll hand it off and waiting for this
big is
right
okay go ahead so
um here are the goals that we started
with see that as John mentioned some of
them are notebook related some of them
are sort of generic diff related
um the plan at this point is to gather
what we have into a packlet that's what
I've been working on and to release that
via the packlet repo
um with the hope that it will eventually
be you know these functions will
eventually migrate back into the product
um and rather than well I'll show The
Proposal ceremony so there's a handful
of functions that we're going to be
talking about today the thing that that
uh knows how to compare items the thing
that knows how to view that comparison
and then some convenience things built
on top of that and and in regards to the
packlet repo I mean we would basically
be ready to publish that today but if if
we end up with some name changes or some
structural changes coming out of this
review we don't want to create a lot of
Confusion by having things that that
change dramatically over time
so the name diff for a thing that's just
called diff really can't make it people
are going to get confused with
differentiation and things uh I I
be hemetly disagree and we can discuss
that when time comes but uh I have very
strong arguments against your position
okay so let me let me demonstrate what
these things actually are
um so we have a couple of lists we want
to understand what the differences are
um diff sort of does everything at once
it looks at these things it Compares a
uh it you know boils down to the longest
common subsequence using sequence
alignment and then displays you know a
thing that has some styling associated
with it
um what this actually did was to to
create a diff object which one can do
directly with this you know this is the
computable representation of the
differences between these Expressions
um
and then using visualizing just that
object using the view diff function you
know so diff is essentially
create the object create the difference
object and show it to me
um but showing it to me is not the only
thing that this object is good for you
can use it right you can say take this
take this patch and apply it to the
initial
list and you'll get back you know the
new list so this is this is a computable
thing
that can be used in interesting ways
um and uh I've built some introspection
features so ways to get the strings out
of you know what is the summary box and
there's a number of other properties
that one can ask for for the diff object
I think should surely be called summary
string or something because the summary
I mean the the you know because one
wants something which has an association
that says additions three removals one
or something or additions deletions
whatever yes let me uh I'll I'll go
ahead and take notes so you don't have
to thank you John okay great
um so I right so I presume you could
apply the diff object not just to a but
anything that's a superset of a so if
you tried like a range of zero through
uh six or whatever it is it would you
know do something sensible well it would
do the positional Replacements that
um that the object represents right so
the object is I'm adding an item at the
beginning I'm removing an item at
location three and I'm adding some
things at the end
um or at not at the end at position five
so that's what this application did so
there's no guarantee if you don't apply
it to the initial lot to the original
object yes you'll get something back
maybe but it but you know whether that's
a meaningful operation or not is you
know that's that's something that a
human needs to think carefully about
okay
um so this is the default view for list
style diffs there are other views that
one other formats for diffs and the
kinds of diffs that are supported the
kind of user supported depend on the
diff object
so for list objects these are the ones
that are supported
um so we can say you know here are the
the two lists as completely separate
items with their items marked up
um we can have sort of a more grid-like
View
uh uh or unified view which is the grid
like but sort of collapse into a single
column
and we can invent you know lots of there
are lots of other things we might do
here
um
uh but right so that's that's why you
know it's it's I think it's important to
have to generate
the the function that creates the diff
object be separate from the function
that views the objects because of this
yeah that's nice okay so that's what I
wanted to demo for lists for Strings
um
we have a new issue because strings you
might want to compare character by
character word by word or line by line
um so generate diff takes an optional
third argument that determines how this
uh how one does this so by default you
get you know if you don't give a third
argument you just get character by
character View and the viewing shows you
you know sort of splits words and
somewhat difficult to read when the
characters happen to be prose
um this maybe is slightly easier to read
uh and of course strings might come from
other places too if you have a peptide
sequence for instance there's a view
where it shows in a more um you know
this is a view that you might see
in biology
uh
right
so that's character by character uh if
you specify words as the third argument
to generate diff or to diff then the
uh you know the granularity is is word
it's a bit easier to make sense of what
the edit was
um and if the string covers multiple
lines then well this is starting to look
like a file so this is an important case
for comparing text files
um but I'll start off with just text
strings we have a range of 10 and here
we have added a couple and we've removed
a couple of things and by default we get
the side-by-side view where and is the
information more or less the same so if
if we opened up that summary box we
would see you know at this lines and
that line correct so this does not carry
any context like uh you know what what a
git diff would where it says not only
where I'm adding it but sort of what's
the nearby stuff so I know
that I am meaningful well so the nearby
stuff is included
um and I will if we look at the input
form of this uh the nearby stuff is in
fact uh stored in the changes object so
here we have a difference here we have a
run of identical elements
um and here we have a difference and a
run of identical elements now these
identical elements might be really long
so there are you know if this was more
than six
you know I would there would be a lesion
here by default
um which you could override but if I
were to chain well let's see do I want
to change this on the Fly here to 30 and
32 and look at the input form of that
we'll see that you know there are these
illusions
you know I'm not carrying around every
bit of context but one could
um and there's an example of that down
the options section below
um right and again so we have the
default view for these guys we have a
unified view uh and shortly when you
talk about text files it'll be important
to have you know a numbered view where
the numbers correspond to you know the
first the first column is the first
element and the second column line
numbers corresponds to the the number in
the second element
is that 18 skeleton one of those more
matches that's correct because I am now
working on an object that I that uh yes
where did I do that
so I did set that to object so the more
matches becomes illusion
um
and I'm not sure what if anything
different this shows but there we go for
strings for text files so what that
shows is you know what happens if you
have a change in addition to right so we
have a purple there
right because I changed five to fifty
rather than deleting it outright right
there are some default stylings green
red blue these are adjustable
um but I'm not sure that I mean we can
talk about that later uh but they are
adjustable
um and for text files I found a couple
of files in the layout that are
remarkably similar
um looks like they were possibly created
by the same person at the same time and
just uh sort of editing things a little
bit
um so you know a real world example of
text file diffing all right
so all that's fairly straightforward now
let's look at notebooks
um
the way that notebooks are handled
notebooks can we can look at we can feed
these guys notebook Expressions notebook
objects notebook files
um of course when you give a notebook
file it needs to be wrapped in fine a
file wrapper because otherwise it could
be treated as a string
um
so that's an important aspect of syntax
and then the diff compares the list of
cells and those are aligned by virtue of
looking at their expression uids this is
especially interesting in the case of
source control where you have edits to
the same file the literal same file with
the same uuids over time and so the
uuids for those cell objects are an
important aspect of you know aligning
these uh these diffs and then cell
grouping and notebook options are
somewhat easier to handle
so here are a couple of simple notebooks
you could probably figure out the diffs
just by looking at these but uh I'm
going to pop them up on the screen here
okay
so again probably see the differences
but I want to show the report that diff
creates by default
um and this is it so we've given it to
notebook expressions in the content
there are two things that happened the
title cell has changed in some way if we
open this up we see a sort of summary of
what that change looked like and we have
a new cell appearing in in the second
notebook
so this report is the default view for
Notebook differencing
um in addition you see the notebook
objects the sorry the notebook options
and the diff object is included just for
people who know how to handle diff
objects I'm not sure that this is going
to appear in the final version of this
we might just extract the summary string
or maybe some other summary bits and
plop them up at the top here as a as a
top sheet of what the changes are
um
all right I'll press on
um so that's interesting but awfully
verbose we'll come back to this that's
okay right well well and and and I think
you know I mean that report that's the
sort of thing that I totally expect that
will at some point not necessarily today
but at some point want to grind down
further to you know to to better
optimize how humans can take it in
absolutely and it's not very interactive
either one wants an interactive thing
and this example is going to show
slightly better interactivity
um here I've grabbed two
uh two CVS commits of a particular
documentation Source notebook uh to
compare them and I've trimmed them down
just to keep the file size of this
agenda notebook small
and if we look at this now it's not so
simple just looking at these guys
there's an addition to removal and some
edits good luck finding them and good
luck having a text diff showing you what
they are
um but here we have
uh a view that shows what they are and
when diffing notebook objects there's
now these links saying a note cell has
changed if I click here and we've scroll
down to the notebooks
to the cell that has changed and now you
might have a chance at visually
inspecting the differences or you can
pop this guy open and see ah okay looks
like somebody removed parentheses
um
and likewise for a remove cell
okay so there's a cell that was removed
that was the remove cell and that's
where it would have been
um Note cell changed again it looks like
parenze
and parens so these commits had to do
with friends why does it say notes is
that because that's the style of those
cells yes
um yes sorry there these this are all
all happen to be in style in cells whose
style uh it was an accident of the
choice of example yeah
um and here we have a cell that was
added after the last cell in this
notebook
um so now again there's this is limited
interactivity one very much wants to say
you know take these two notebooks and
create a new notebook by grabbing some
diffs you know I want I want to accept
this change I want to reject this
removal Etc
um and that's something that we have the
the kernel features for we don't have
the interface for just yet
um
right so and then I had some sort of
summarized abbreviated views of the same
object to give you a more visceral
uh sense of what the diffs are so here's
a sort of whimsical view of you know
cells that are the same or white cells
that are edited or blue remove yeah you
get the idea
um and likewise a thing that shows you
know here are the sales you started with
here the ones you finish with and this
is what happened in the meantime so here
we have a cell that didn't exist that
now does so that didn't that did exist
and that doesn't in some edits and
depending on the size of the notebook
number of cells these might be useful
visualizations and there's probably lots
more
um right so and then I mean those could
also interact with the notebook history
stuff they could they could be
interactive they couldn't they could
interact I mean they also could indicate
how old the cell was and things
Sorry by interact you mean the the this
kind of visualization yeah yeah could
could be informed by The Notebook
history yeah I agree
um yes we could give special attention
to cell change times in these
visualizations yes
uh uh right so and in this report we've
already seen what I'm doing for cell
differencing
um but I'll give a little bit more
detail on Cell differencing directly of
course we have cell cell object and the
cell generators these are all supported
by the functions you know diff and
generate diff
track differences in format type in the
contents the contents of a seller broken
down into uh string tokens this is true
in both Text data and box data and then
those are compared as a flat list and
then restyled
um
right so I don't dig we don't have sort
of recursive
differencing in type setting just yet we
have sort of a this is a flat the robot
is is taken as a flat list and I'll show
I'll show I'll I'll demonstrate that in
a second so here's a couple of cells
extracted from various points in the
history of a manipulate guide page
um
and
this is the differences between them
should be clear the cell style didn't
change some of the options changed some
of the contents changed
um
right and for box data here I'm just
going to evaluate a couple of integrals
so we have a couple output cells here
I'm going to grab the cell object sorry
sorry Lou back on the text case uh so
you are choosing words as the defaults
uh view effectively this is equivalent
to the string words correct the the
token I'm tokenizing this as strings yes
which I for text cells seem like the
natural thing to do yeah but but not
just strings but as sorry sorry as word
specific words yes I misspoke okay
um
right so let's grab the cell objects for
uh the previous output and the output
before that one so oops so we have C1 C2
are now these output cells and we
compare them and we see that uh the
Difference Engine thinks that there were
four edits what were they
um
so we have
uh uh X
root root X Plus X root negative root X
Plus X as I said these are not recursive
yet so this could go into the square
root box and determine that the
difference was sort of more isolated it
doesn't get
um that will be some work
um and
you know other things
are highlighted in green and red some of
these things I mean one of the things
I'm concerned about is when the
differences are small
you know this is a very small sliver of
color to distinguish these to make the
colors bigger we should make it a Blog a
quad that has the minus sign inside it
could you have a minimum size for the
Box okay yeah that's a good idea
um
but other visualizations of these cell
differences we could look at just the
contents which just is exactly what you
see here but without the paraphernalia
um I took tried my hand at you know
recombining these things and showing the
differences next to one another maybe
above one another would have been
slightly clearer
um I think above would be better yeah uh
and likewise there's a view that lets
you not just get the changes object but
sort of a digested version of the
computable data so that you can have
other you know so somebody could digest
this form and extract it and use it in
their own interface or their own
whatever
um sort of exposing a bit to the
implementation of the cell differencing
um
right
so and as John pointed out at the
beginning you know now that we have cell
differencing this is really you know
arbitrary Expressions can appear in
cells so we have arbitrary expression
differencing as well
um I have some convenience
uh Arguments for that so we have you
know here's here's an argument that says
all right coerce these things to their
input form strings and compare them as
strings this is coerce them to standard
form cells and compare them as cells
um
so I expect these to be sort of the high
level versions of things that people
generally want when comparing
expressions
okay
um
so there's one other kind of diff that's
important for Source control and that is
a three-way diff where you have an
original and you have two different
people who have edited this thing in two
different ways and you need to merge
them back together and sometimes that's
possible and sometimes there's a
conflict we don't have a function that
does this alignment in the Wolfram
language yet I've written one
multi-alignment which is essentially an
extension of sequence alignment that
allows these I mean multiple sequence
alignment in biology means something
completely different
I didn't know that
yeah and I do not have a strong opinion
on this
on the name on the name
yeah I don't think that's the right name
okay uh be that as it may here is how it
works so we have an original expression
we have one person edited it to add
something at the beginning in the end we
have another person who edited it to
do other things and we see this
completely opaque multi-alignment with
lots of nested lists and to visualize it
so generate diff uses notebook alignment
the art these the the syntax that I've
chosen for now to keep this to be two
arguments is to have the original and
then when you give a list of two
different
I mean but how does generate diff not
just think it's
if a rig was a
listing right this is okay so there is
there is a difficulty here
um where a list a pair in the second
argument is Meaningful maybe we need to
have this be another argument or it
can't look that way okay but for now uh
this has noticed that the
multi-alignment
carries information about additions
removal and a conflict
um and then we view that and we see okay
we see the addition there's an addition
there's removal
um
uh but
somebody so this guy added two things
after the original this guy added
something after the original as well so
there's no way by default to know you
know where these should be with regard
to one another so that's conflict
um
and this is very common in Source
control to have merging tools the goal
here is to eventually have some Wolfram
language scripts that could be attached
to
that you could set up as an external
diffing utility for your get client
Mercurial client CDs client Etc so that
this would all just work uh and go into
the Wolfram technology stack and and you
know either do the merging or provide
some information about a white can't now
is that is there a way to do that kind
of call out from git well git clients
tend to have ways to do that yes I don't
know
git has a uh a way to hook into external
tools uh so they have uh there's a thing
called a git diff tool and a thing
called a git merge tool and this is
basically git providing a bunch of
standardized information to a tool of
your choice uh where you can then use
that tool to resolve uh to either
visualize or resolve as the case may be
uh the conflict
right
so from language script is really the
the only possible way of tying into well
it's our best it's our best solution for
talking yeah I think
um
Okay so
right so those are the functions there
are a couple palettes I built on top of
those functions
um since I have the packlet installed I
have those palettes here
um for comparing cells in place so here
let me okay uh and for comparing
notebooks as well
um this actually was very useful in the
last hour etai and I were going back and
forth with edits to this agenda notebook
and we were editing it simultaneously
and so it was my job to you know sort of
merge etai's edits back into what I was
working on so this was a very this you
know has real world
uh street cred already anyway uh and
I've also built out a thing that
actually it's been in stashling for a
while there's a utility for extracting a
file out of a one of our
stash.wolfrom.com repos and comparing
you know one branch against another so
you can see you know what happened to
core between our previous release and
our current setup or whatever
um
so this is going to be very useful
internally it might be something that we
can package up in a way for external
folks but uh
uh right so that's that's coming and and
and something that's not represented
here right you know I it's it's in the
kind of more tools to build on top of
this but one of the things which we have
done in gitlink uh is is we've said uh
so get link is still operating in the
line by in the world of line by line
diffs only uh but it's not just
operating on notebooks it's operating on
all kinds of files uh and uh the uh uh
and we've said in some cases when there
is a git conflict uh try this strategy
for merging it and the strategy might be
a line by line strategy for example if
we know the file is a bunch of messages
and you know there might oftentimes be a
conflict because someone adds message a
to the end of the list and someone else
adds message B to the end of the list
well just take both and the order
doesn't even matter that's a strategy
that's a strategy
um yeah and then you know if it's a
notebook you know forget the line by
line diffs you know for certain kinds of
notebooks you know you can just process
it as a notebook file and and we do this
in uh uh for style sheets for example
um so that changes to say core.mb we can
have multiple changes and get link and
figure it out so I you know some of
those strategies we've already
thought about forget link I think you
know can evolve from the work here as
well all right let's let's not look at
the options yet okay
right
okay
this is great you know waiting for it
for 20 years or more
let's start in on some of the issues by
the way let me let me um perhaps you can
unshare for a second let me show you
something just for amusement
um
now
sorry I'm just I have to rearrange
something yeah
uh
most
about that
oh my gosh too many things
um
okay
it might amuse you something I was
literally just working on yesterday
um
this is
this is um
multi-way evaluation paths
notice these objects here
see what they are
they're basically the diffs of
expressions
interesting
I mean I'm not vertical yes yeah they're
vertical and that I mean this formatting
is not right yet but but these are just
to understand what this is because it's
you know the evaluator is basically
going actually there's a multi-way
evaluator so there's a more
sophisticated thing but it's going from
an expression through an event which is
the diff basically to another expression
see what I'm saying so in a sense you
know the whole story you can think of
the evaluator as being you could imagine
running your diffs on the before and
after for the evaluator
and you will get an event which
corresponds to the death
see what I'm saying
yep
just an FYI okay back to your back to
your screen
okay let's dig in here
okay
all right
so
generate death
all right so first of all I mean I'm
sure you're doing this but in the diff
object you obviously should version the
diff object so that you know we can put
all kinds of weird stuff into the diff
object and one day we might change our
diff objects but we don't want all the
old diff objects to become
uh you know to become bad right
I don't think I am but that's an
excellent idea
okay
yeah so you need to put something in
there for you know
um whatever yeah
uh or a diff version or something
um
okay so then
all right so hold on a second try
uh
okay now you're saying how are you
different right that third element that
third argument
right what are you caring about
right
um
by the way I suspect that this three-way
diff
probably should be a separate function
Maybe
um
because I think it's going to need
different options in the end but anyway
the the what are you caring about so the
list you have right now which sort of
reminds me of import formats
and or it reminds me of word count
character count Etc
you know what I'm saying
so can you show the list of elements
that you have now for generic diff
um it depends let's see can I yes I
think I can hold on let me look at
sources
uh
and then we need an analogy to this and
I suspect the analogy is the Importer
anybody got comments on that
worse characters
um characters is misnamed strings in
this list
okay so it should be called characters
yep
and I don't understand what lists means
is that list elements or what
yes
it means list elements
as opposed to cell lists which have you
know sort of special handling let's be
clear what these things are these are
the unit the granularity of
of of comparison right
well not exactly granularity but right
because like input form standard form
it's like okay we've done that then
that's not the right thing there I mean
most of these I mean maybe we can elide
this list to include some of those but
in the first approximation
I would assume this is
diff by character diff by line diff by
word
right and it's also diff by input form
no but it's then dipped by input form by
character diff by input form by
something else right that's correct yeah
right
so
I you know look I think
um okay so let me make a suggestion here
so could you because that list again
okay so let's just go through what that
list actually means all right the first
thing is
is it just a list or if I have F of a b
c f of a b d or something does it do the
same thing there it will not for now
um
it will say I can't do that so there are
there are only some expressions are
supported by default we could go
straight to
one of the you know renderings like if
you have two polynomials it might make
perfect sense to do a diff okay but but
so what you're saying is a diff of what
though of the of the full form of the
input form of the standard form that's
that's well I think that's the point
that the diff actually is a semantic
diff in that case more semantic
okay let's just go through these and
understand what they are okay the first
thing is list elements basically
correct
can we make some notes maybe on your
left hand side don't whatever you want
to find uh John was taking notes but
sure uh just just make it could you not
obscure that thing Stephen let me do one
thing at a time please yeah okay sorry
it's all right don't matter
um I have many questions this is very
wonderful stuff I have many questions
um okay so that first thing is list
elements right the second thing is
characters
the third thing genuinely is lights
right it's
as long as you understand it's lines of
of text
well then write a comment text lines
then
no just text lines text lines one word
text lines I'm getting there yeah okay
okay
okay words all right what's notebooks
what does that mean
that's the diff object that represents
when you're comparing full a full
notebook against another full notebook
but what granularity are you comparing
with
it's just it's essentially the
granularity of the uh cell for the
contents but it's also comparing uh
notebook options as well
okay so I can imagine you know let's say
you have F of ABC and G of ABC that's
not what you've covered in lists but you
might have something where you are
comparing expressions
yeah you know there's several other
people who are who are might be relevant
for this meeting like Nick might be
relevant because he's been working on a
bunch of these uh
things Christopher might be relevant
other people several other people might
be relevant and should probably be asked
about this stuff at some point no I mean
Christopher is optional for this meeting
he has chosen not to show up but maybe
somebody should ping him and tell them
what we're talking about he might show
up
somebody do that please
yeah
is Nicholas is optional for this meeting
which Nick
a mother
no because we were told he cannot be in
any meetings
that's not right
that was somebody was confused very
confused
no matter
um very very confused
okay take that separately offline
okay
um
Solace what does that mean
so this the distinction between cellist
cells is you know this is one cell
versus another cell
and this is the list of cells from a
notebook this is the sales part of the
of what it is doing it's the first
notebook
okay what does input form mean is that
character by character input form
it is character by character yes right
because for what I mean you could maybe
possibly being words but lines does not
make sense for input form because it
could be totalized
yes could be tokens it could be tokens
all right so can you make a note that
that's either characters or tokens
now standard form
characters is pretty funky for standard
form
isn't it I mean that's mostly tokens
well currently it's only tokens right
yeah right that's basically
stick the standard form in the cell and
diff to sell
correct
which uses the tokens that I was
describing so I'm just I'm just I'm just
looking at these okay so hold on hold on
hold on so first thing is these are a
mess and we need to figure out how to
get these better
but
I do understand the value of having a
diff with respect to something
okay
okay then we've got the three-way diff
which
is rather obscurely to me generating a
diff object I don't know why it's
generating a diff object rather than a
diff three object or something
you know I mean
how common is a three-way diff and is it
would it make sense to say you know
generate diff
you know a diff two and a diff three
object for example
Christopher is here
okay
this is we're talking about uh a general
diff capability for Expressions
notebooks files Etc
they had a long right although I thought
okay so there's actually because I mean
expression diffing has been like
every one of these categories expression
different and notebook dipping have both
been like these these things okay the
Holy Grail has now been captured
and Lou has said okay great right I mean
I I wouldn't say that General expression
diffing but if you're willing to
you know look at in its you know input
form or standard form then we have
General expression diffing beyond that
we have lists strings cells and
notebooks
yeah I was jumping in to say exactly the
same thing so
um
but to your question this evening of how
common are three-way diffs I think in
the context of source control they're
extremely common outside of source
control they're probably not at all for
Christmas benefit just open up one thing
where you're showing a cool picture of a
diff that's happened just just to give
some sense of what's here
sure
oh
yeah okay oh nice so it's quite
developed but needs polishing
and also show Christopher the the the
Box uh the the standard form boxes the
that's what well okay right uh okay
that's in this cells I think it says
cells yeah
yeah
um oh it's still generated there you go
so nice I'll repeat it's not a full
recursive diff so for instance the
square this outer square root box isn't
in fact different from one to the other
but for now these are treated as sort of
flat lists of tokens
um
incidentally I don't know whether you've
I mean I know at the summer school
several years ago somebody did a quite
extensive project on tree diffing we
looked at it
okay
who looked at it more than I did I don't
remember what is assessment we came to
frankly I don't remember either but um
it wasn't so much stuff that we thought
that we could use
right I mean I think if I remember right
I mean there have been several different
projects summer school I think over many
years but like the usual problem is that
they end up with the the like being very
fine-grained so like if you give it I
mean this is a uh right it's like for
example in Tech stiffing you you can see
this as well and like kind of not very
good algorithms which is like if you
give two pieces of just unrelated text
and the correct thing is to say you
deleted one piece of text and replace it
to another but instead it says well
actually this space was actually kept
and you know this space was was actually
not changed but but you know all the
letters around it were and you can kind
of like Cobble together one string from
another and I don't know there are a lot
of problems like that you can clear it's
more of a heuristic thing than uh purely
mathematics sequence alignment hopefully
has taken care of some of that for
Strings and not being stupid like that I
don't know
I'm not sure and I'm not sure it should
necessarily because I feel like once you
start kind of
a lot of that's kind of more heuristic
stuff that's useful for humans looking
at diffs but isn't otherwise
yeah I will say my work is built on
sequence alignment which has options and
if there are certain values of these
options that are better for Strings than
other values then I would very much like
to learn about that so that I could use
it automatically you should find that
out I don't know the answer I mean maybe
the bioinformatics folk will know
something about that okay
um
all right let's let's go back up here so
the thing we were we were talking about
let's go through the survey of what we
have to look at from a design point of
view so first thing is the granularity
of the diff and you know we've still got
a bit of a mess here with how we specify
those granularities
I mean that that is the right way to
think about this it's granularity well
both actually it's two things it's the
granularity and the target of the death
okay but what do I mean by Target that
is is it the list of cells in a notebook
or Does it include the notebook options
themselves you know as well that type of
thing right so there's two different
issues here
is it you know are we looking at
character by character or word by word
or line by line and are we looking at
certain kinds of metadata so for example
you could imagine a diff here an image
diff for instance
right and the image shift might or might
not look at the XF
making sense right yes
so there's really two issues granularity
and Target I believe is there anything
else here that you are oh and there's
another one which is
um uh filtering which is input form
standard form traditional form so this
granularity Target and filtering could
you make I would call this coercion
rather than filtering okay fine
um
on fingers
is it really collagen I mean in other
words if one of them but it's to both of
them right so it's not
this was just syntactic sugar on top of
a thing that you could already get
without these right or what
well no you could just say generate diff
of two string of expression comma input
form
comma two string of another expression
coming in I form I see I see okay all
right the first thing is yeah yeah you
get it
okay so the second syntactic issue we
have is the three-way diff
I think that should be generate diff
three or something like that
because I think that there's no way to
untangle that syntax mess of having two
plus also is there a four-way diff
not usually
yeah but I mean is it something we can
imagine
so
git has a multi-merge I think they call
an octo merge uh facility
but
it well it's the sort of thing that I
mean people care deeply that it works
but nobody understands what it does
except for you know true domain experts
but what they care about is the merge
right for that from that right right
okay
So Okay so we've got this we've got view
diff which we're going to talk about I'm
not sure that name is right we don't
have a lot of other views in the system
but that's the diff format
that's the that's showing diffs in
different ways
with colored backgrounds and this that
and the other
and but generate diff generates a diff
object
that okay so when you say apply a diff
there's no point in applying a diff to
the thing you just dipped right you're
applying a diff to something different
to something where I mean my God it
reminds me or you're sending or you're
sending the patch to someone else to
apply it yeah I know I'm remembering
when I first used a Time shared computer
system in 1976 everything was based on
patch files
for some reason of saving storage right
they didn't want you know program files
and so on to be replicated and so
everything was in a patch
this is also the way that CVS and before
at RCS uh yes and before it the thing
that I think I was using in 97.
it's it's 1976 it was probably sccs
it's I think that might have even been
more modern than this it was I remember
that the um the uh CDC computers had had
a whole fancy version of this
um anyway no matter so as as a point of
interest it's not the core ma uh the
core model upon which git operates now
there are some implementational details
that kind of fudge what the what the
operating model should be uh but uh uh
but in principle the way git operates is
uh is you actually have a complete and
separate copy uh of each and every
iteration uh of course uh you know if
copies happen to be identical then you
know you don't get multiple copies
because of content addressability well
it's because git was developed long
after all these other systems and when
storage was all much cheaper yeah
and it was developed by someone who
thought you know who had uh uh expertise
in file systems and he designed git as
if it were a file system
that's an interesting statement
and I mean you know I'm not making uh
you know a genius meta-analysis I mean
he's he's said uh as much
okay but so so to what extent are we
adopting the CVS model instead of the
get model here in some way or is that
not how I should think about it I mean
we're imagining we're imagining a
typical workflow is okay so let's give
an example of like blogs I write
which have a source and then maybe they
were already converted into some other
form and then I make a change and
somebody needs to dip it and I believe
we have some tools that do that right
now but this will be a better version of
those tools right
and here
yeah
um
yeah sorry not a live stream is
commenting maybe it should be diff
generated diff view Etc rather than
having diff second that's a I was going
to bring up a similar thing
um I I have to admit I'm I'm still a
little weak on our general principles of
when we use object verb or yeah I'm
afraid I'm I am too I mean
you know there's some cases which are
angry oh darn it because I was depending
on you no I I definitely have a feeling
for this but I mean there are some
anchor cases where it's clear it has to
be one way round or the other but then
there is sort of a we're stringing
things in the middle and those are a
little bit less clear
okay I think what we often do what I'll
claim we often do is is it's usually
noun verb
if nothing else to make autocomplete
nicer
um but then it's only verb noun for
certain things that like that are
consistent like they're always there
like Constructors like if it's create
blah yeah create first usually
um but then any operations will be noun
verb
so it's sort of certain privileged verbs
that tend to want to be first right
exactly correct yes that's my argument
we're going to put it in which case this
would be definitively diff generate
well wait unless it's uh
uh
generate or create is sort of a
privileged verb I'm not sure
primary privilege one we do have things
that generate symmetric key oh that's
true we do yes we do so generators is
possible but view we've never had
right then that would be this view or
something
yeah we can't have generate different
diff View
that's unrememberable
okay let's let's continue here for a
second so that's that's the thing we
need to consider but now
okay
I mean I'm kind of feeling like
is the diff object that you get from a
three-way diff is it a different it's
different from a two-way diff isn't it
the diff the diff object thing
well it has different contents well that
means it's different well no I mean it
has the same
it yeah
I mean it's the same structure it's just
instead of a the changes list instead of
each element having a pair when things
are when there's a difference it's a
triple
right and then you know and and so I I
think lose reticence here is saying I'm
not reluctant I'm describing well a
potential reticence is is analogizing to
for example you have points in 2D
objects and points in 3D objects which
are in a way fundamentally different but
in a way quite similar yeah right
um
okay so you're saying we could have a
list I mean if we were doing the octopus
death whatever it is that in principle
that structure could be occupied
so to speak
there it could be a four-way diff as
well
that structure doesn't doesn't limit it
correct three way correct yes
okay but now apply diff
if you've given a three
a three-way diff object if your object
is a three-way diff object what the heck
does apply diff do
it would effectively be a merge
right it it takes the original and it
applies both
it applies both sets of edits as long as
there is no conflicting edit
I see
so it's a union
it's a diff Union
unless there's a I mean an in practice
Supply diff with a three-way diff object
if there was a emerge conflict diff you
know a conflict then it would just get
an error message and fail is that
correct but but apply diff could also be
the the container by which you express a
uh conflict uh resolution strategy
which we don't yet have here is that
true
correct we having git link but we don't
yet have here yeah but the conflict
strategy could be you know Jim always
wins type thing or something yeah right
I mean the the the most trivial
strategies which are useful in certain
contexts is uh left side always wins
right side always wins or you know merge
or take both you know kind of I think
both of you can yeah and
right
um
okay but I think you're right Stephen in
that apply diff or whatever we call it
is really most interesting in the in
this case in the three-way merge case in
the two-way case it's it's a it's unless
you're sending patches around
it's a trivial you know you probably
would never need this
but but that is useful I mean one of the
one of the core use cases for certain
git users I mean you know not as much
for your kind of average everyday git
user but but this was a core use case
analytics is being able to uh send
around patch files
well I know that was the core use case
in 1976 as well
but do we have a use case for patch
files
well
um actually we do let me give you a
scenario okay so somebody has written a
hell
maybe well I could certainly imagine
you know a programmatic use
right where you're like apply the change
I can infer from here to these other
guys
yes
well I'm I was thinking I have a
function that I've written somebody has
a change there tell me to that function
okay here's a question I I don't think
this is plausible
no it's not gonna work I mean if it's
like I've got these functions and I've
changed the way that I'm doing options
or error handling in these functions
there's no way I can specify that with
diffs no way
this is much more it's much too close to
literal
I mean I wouldn't say no way but I would
agree that it's impractical
yeah I mean this the apply diff for a
two-way diff is is primarily the you
know 50 year old patch file idea
yeah
which seems to me like it doesn't have a
great use in modern times
okay now multi-alignment
okay
one comment about it so I mean you know
the big use case in Linux development
is
when you're dealing with multiple
contributors
so it's not just you know
person a feeding uh a patch to person B
it's you know persons A1 A2 A3 and A4
all feeding interesting but different
patches
to person B
I see when they don't conflict
I mean well but you apply a patch then
you apply another patch
and because the patches because the diff
objects have enough context
they can be they're non-conflicted you
know it's so bizarre I mean I mean
there's no guarantee if non-con
confliction but it can happen quite
often though I know what's so bizarre is
this is so
similar to these
this is the difference between
space-like separation and branch-like
separation in our physics project
terms
space-like separation is things happen
at different places in space and they
happen independently branch-like
separation means things happen on two
different branches in history perhaps at
the same place
so that's what you're describing so long
as it's space like separated you're all
good you can apply the diffs if it's
branch-like separated they have a
conflict
um
so
I see so so basically many space-like
separated diffs are
in other words not but I think it's not
a totally useless way to say it because
it means that their diffs too different
to different places basically yes yes
right
yes right and in fact you know to uh
you know well the the situation with
with Linux that John was describing it's
really you have a11 through a1n
sending to B1 and then you know a21
through a2m sending to B2
Etc and you know enough chains of this
up to you know Linus and he he you know
he applies the mega patches that were
sort of created by unioning in previous
stages so do we have a patch unioning
system
that would be multiple diff objects that
are being unioned into a single death
object
right it's
it's have a diff object algebra in that
regard but I don't think it's insane to
make one
okay I I you know I mean you know we
have to question
what directions are the most valuable to
proceed yeah I understand but that's
plausible But but so to some extent
merge the function merge that is used
for associations has also a
a um
a way of dealing with conflicts right
if you look up merge documentation for
merge
somewhat unsurprisingly
yeah supplied to list survives that
share the same key
so that's the that's the precedent we
have
for how a merge could be done
right so I mean in your left most right
most it's either first last whatever
else
so is that right I mean is that does
that make sense that's that's the that
is the
the conflict resolution function yeah
yeah it's a conflict resolution function
for apply diff
uh what we did we expressed it as an
option
uh and that option takes certain string
values that makes sense uh I mean it can
take a raw function as well but the
string values were are the common cases
for which you know we have the
functionality embedded therein
yeah that makes sense I think that's the
right way to do it
okay can we go back sorry to the left
hand side if we remove that that thing
um
okay this multi-alignment which I think
cannot I mean I believe in
bioinformatics that really means
something different you have to ask
uh
you know sequence alignment does not
produce the most beautiful output it is
readable
you know we've had there was a summer
school project thing to make a pretty
print of a sequence alignment which I'm
pretty sure isn't the function
Repository
but what you're providing here should be
you know view diff you had applicable to
a raw sequence alignment output didn't
you yes you did because you showed a
bioinformatics example
um it wasn't
directly to sequence line I'm I'm using
SQL alignment behind the scenes to do
this alignment but you should be able to
take a sequence alignment output
and
visualize it
using
hmm
you know use using this it's just a
minor convenience
now you know you've got to understand
that I don't know how sequence alignment
is
I mean again there are all kinds of
biology specific heuristics that get
you know packaged up into things like
blast although that works that's
slightly different that's a matching
thing
but
okay I mean
and you know in the bioinformatics world
there's a sort of the indels you know
this concept of indel and social and
deletion indel and substitution as being
the which is also what you're using here
insertion deletion substitution right
well I'm using it because sequence
alignment uses it but yes no I
understand that but I mean the basic
operation because in Biology another
operation is two things got flipped
around
which you're not correct coffee number
changes you know which I don't think is
relevant for this
um although it's worth bearing that in
mind yeah it it should be said that you
know I mean elsewhere
those are operations that uh that I
think lots of people would like to see
in diff outputs generally but I'm not
aware of any broad-based diffing type of
tool that actually works doing those
kinds of operations
okay I would love to see a got flipped
with B but uh nobody's doing that
probably because it's quite hard
I don't guarantee it's that hard because
it's done in bioinformatics
right although it may not I mean that
may be non-trivial algorithms I don't
really know
and I thought well that's also a very
limited
uh you know alphabet
yeah that might help that might help
there's definitely string algorithms
which we'll use hashing but that would
help and you know part of what makes it
hard is oh it got flipped but then it
got flipped and then minor modifications
made
sure
like we should look well there are
algorithms for that but that's a future
enhancement that's definitely not for
right now
but whatever
look sequence alignment okay there is a
thing multiple sequence alignment okay
which is used
it's like the the precursor to those to
protein folding the old the the pre the
last few months protein folding
technology
uh
I don't know exactly what that I I've
seen the outputs from those things and
that they are you know what you would
expect there are multiple versions of of
sequence level you've got to ask
somebody how this works
and maybe in fact it is the concept you
want
it might actually be a concept you want
I'm not sure
okay so are you suggesting if it's the
concept we want then maybe the name is
appropriate yes but then then it's got
to be an end way thing
because that's actually useful and I I
think you might find our biophanex team
has actually been building this
as I say it isn't it is what's that even
better yeah it's built yeah yeah
okay
so now okay so we have to straighten out
this granularities business sorry um
who's who's the point person
Michael you can start with Michael we
won't be the actual person let's start
with Michael
um
there's a new person who's working on
this stuff is probably the right person
but
um
okay
I have to go somewhere else soon hip and
this we should set up another custom
meeting about this topic
uh
but
okay
you want to talk about diff on its own
at all
the function
has it well the name because at the
beginning you had some concerns it's all
about differentiation my concerns about
differentiation are melting okay
what do you think about that so uh
remember we had this discussion not so
long ago about uh about the option that
is used for uh for coding ligatures and
at the time you talked me down from I
don't remember what the name was but a
name that used the you know the term
ligature uh and uh and talked me into
something else and now I have to keep
reminding you what the name of that
option is yeah because you keep asking
what is the name of the option that does
coding ligatures
it's operator appearances
okay not up it's not automatic operator
rendering
uh oh sorry it might be uh
sorry auto operator renderings yeah
something like that yes
so the
this the problem is my object lesson in
not not backing down when you know the
world has a really standardized name for
this well except the coding ligatures is
not a standard name
kind of is
I know I know I know it's one of these
names which once invented turns out to
be the right name
yeah
and I agree that diff is a is is a very
generic name
so fine I mean I think it's a
now
you know okay so
I don't understand why diff
doesn't have a print form I mean is the
output of diff is the output view diff I
don't even understand why there is a
view diff why doesn't a diff object just
display as by default
as a diff
well I mean ultimately
uh I think that uh it's going to be very
useful to specify different ways of
viewing diffs
and I certainly don't think that we want
to encourage people to do that by
re-running the diff all over again
no I agree so what I'm suggesting is
this okay you run the diff
with diff or something okay and it
produces for you
let's say diff is the is the main
function that actually is the active
function diff produces a diff object
diff object formats
as a viewed diff now you can tell it
different and then we have a another you
know a possibly like we do with show and
things like this
I don't know whether this works with the
argument structure but possibly
something like this isn't quite right
but but what we would do in other cases
we would basically say diff again on the
diff object comma format well this won't
work with notebook objects right because
the the view is something that doesn't
live in The Notebook
um
okay
and you know I think it's also quite
unyieldy to you know write cut you know
copy this enormous looking thing instead
of a small summary box to say oh I and
when you want to say oh I want to view
this some other way
well the other thing we've done for the
notebook case is which we've done for
Notebook objects and so on is is it a
summary box but it has an opener Arrow
but what you get in the notebook is it's
just the summary box but you click a
button in it to open it as a separate
notebook
you see what I'm saying
we've got more to grind on this okay
we're going to get a this is it we're
close but not this isn't right yet
there's a there's a way of doing this I
think where you just well basically
here's what happens you type diff you
get a diff object the diff object
displays as a reasonable formatted
version of the of the diff maybe a
minimal version of the diff and then
maybe it has a raft or something else
that lets you open it out into whatever
object whatever format you want if you
didn't specify a format when you
specified the original diff
okay I also strongly suspect that that
third argument to death is going to wind
up being something that is a bit like
places where we use rules that say
Source destination
and might be that the
I I don't know I'm I'm just I'm I'm not
sure yet but but can you imagine one
definite place that I'm not familiar
with Source destination okay so they're
like text translation
text translation
Lang one Lang two see that so one
translates into the into the language
Lang and the other translates from Lang
one to Lang two
and what I'm imagining is something
where
the right hand side is kind of the
format you want it to end up and I don't
think it's quite right that's not quite
right now I think this is I mean I think
your idea about it being more like uh
import export
um you know uh elements is is better
is a closer analogy yeah
but then
uh
all right but I think
and then
for the application of a diff
I'm wondering if it can just be a
sub-value
now I understand you want sub buddies
for the diff object but maybe if you I
don't know again I'm not sure I don't I
right so what I'm saying you just you
just take a diff object and you apply it
to something
that may not be right because no because
because in the case of strings you can't
disambiguate all right okay and you have
to give conflict options
yeah yeah I don't think that okay that
won't work
um
okay
but then I I do Wonder ux wise I mean if
you look at if you if you scroll down to
some of your display forms
for these things
I do feel like
there could be you know by the time
you're formatting that type of stuff you
could have something which allows you to
choose to flip around formats so to
speak either with a raft or with an
element in the actual you know displayed
object itself
right and I've had that in mind as an
interface that could be built on top of
these raw elements
um but yes that could be sort of burned
into the elements themselves I suppose
right I'm just I mean I think you know
that's a pretty sensible you know
default formatting there the you know
the the the table looking one yeah with
openers but I'm what I'm arguing is you
know if you want to do something with
that you know copying that into an input
cell it's going to be kind of obnoxious
as opposed to just the summary box of a
diff object
I understand if you want to copy it that
way as opposed to calling it percent
seven or something right
so I mean you could say that about every
expression we generate oh it's too
complicated you're not going to want to
copy it into an input cell well that's
and that's why we have summary boxes for
a lot of things some things right but
the question is we okay the trade office
and that that's also why we have image
size multipliers
so an image automatically drops down
when you start typing around it to make
it less unwieldy
yeah that's also a good point but I mean
the point is that the place where it's a
summary blob is makes sense is the case
where you really don't you know there
isn't a good way to see the thing
in summary form you know it's it's a
giant sparse array there's nothing you
could display there that will be a
reasonable faithful representation of
the sparse array whereas here there is
there is something you can display and
you might as well display it up to it I
agree up to a degree I mean even right I
mean that's the equivalent of sparse
array of you know one two zero zero zero
six yeah fine
well okay then then I've got another
comment if there if it is the case that
the thing is you know I wasn't going to
say too big too big to show type thing
okay
then I think we need a different
format for the thing we need something
which has a lesion built into it so that
the thing you show isn't too big to show
I mean it's like data set you could say
it's too big to show but we have paging
in a data set yeah I I mean it's and
this is common in every diffing
interface I see you know there are only
two possibilities one is they find some
way to say if it's too large we're not
going to show it unless you really want
us to or it you know becomes crushed
under computational load and unusable
right so okay so fine so then then what
we would do here is it's like a too big
for example you know like like the like
the um what do we call it output size
limiter yes
right it's like that kind of thing where
if it's if it's you know we show a
certain amount of the diff
making it clear that this is just a diff
frame
right where you're seeing a window into
the death
up to a certain size
that seems like a very sensible way to
do it and that way you can pick it up
because it never gets too big and you
can use it you know what I'm saying
and that way you get Best of Both Worlds
and also like the output size limiter we
could do exactly the same ux approach we
could have a a tray at the bottom that
has options for what you can do with it
because this thing isn't a an end in
itself it's a thing that you're going to
use in some way
I like that idea
you know frame it say it
right and one of those buttons could be
convert to summary box if that's what
you want exactly
yes yes and then you can and then you
know which is analog of iconize which we
have for the the two big thing I think
yep
which might be the thing for this as
well it might be iconized as well here
so operational question we're going to
meet again is there someone who's not
here now that we should bring into the
next meeting
um
I don't know anybody wants a I mean
maybe Nick if we're going to get very
algorithmic on this I don't know if
there's anybody else maybe somebody from
bioinformatics Team
oh and another person we should bring in
is somebody who's been involved in docky
tools blog tools
Brian or somebody else you ask Brian I
don't know
okay
so reach out to Brian reach out to M
chart
yeah yes
okay
you know we're finally knocking off all
these things that we've been planning to
do for years good stuff
yeah this is really going to be useful
you know I mean it's it's it's been a
hard problem
you know yeah
we've got a lot of Genius stuff
behind the scenes here that we haven't
even touched on so
fair enough I mean and we also need to
talk about notebook distance or we got
another solid hour hour and a half
meeting ahead of us on this but we're
you know we're gonna grind this is going
to get a bit more polished it's going to
be great
okay all right thanks a lot guys okay
see ya